there's this amazing satellite dish on
the on the top of Rockefeller Center
they have this amazing satellite dish
that that can get literally hundreds of
channels from all over the globe a lot
of like specialized cable channels that
I had no idea even existed right I mean
it's really amazing and we spent a lot
of time at the show looking at all these
really cool channels yep
and I thought this is so great it's
really cool that we work here and we can
do that but people at home they don't
get to see these cool channels no they
don't they I mean that's NBC money they
can shell out that big money for a dish
like that exactly and that's why because
they've got the cash we're not getting
any of it but they've got the cash so I
thought it might be a little might be
fun tonight to do some channel surfing
and see what these stations have to
offer and share these really cool
stations with everybody at home I think
people would like to see that
I have here a I got a cable guide here
ant list you can see how fake this thing
it lists all kinds of different cable
channels and we can get most of these
which is pretty cool for example we can
get CNN right there which a lot of
you're thinking no big deal everybody
gets it everyone gets CNN and we get The
Weather Channel right here which right
there Jana yeah that's boring that's
what everybody gets right yay yeah those
are like those are just ones that
anybody can yeah didn't get him but look
at this one right here this one looks
pretty cool it's called the marital
bliss news network
marital bliss news yeah
marital bliss news I don't quite know
what it is but I thought we should check
that out um I don't think a lot of
people get this one listen good evening
I'm Doug Sampson and I'm Emily Sampson
and this is the marital bliss news
network's evening edition would you like
to start tonight honey no you go first
baby Thank You pumpkin tonight's top
story takes us to Bangladesh where
countless thousands have been reported
missing after a major typhoon no honey
the actual figure was 742 okay rescuers
had to wait five hours until daylight to
begin their rescue we know not at all
they began rescue efforts with light
provided by a series of generators but
then there was a fire so they have to
wait until daylight okay are you done
yeah just get it right Thank You
prevailing sense of hope that things can
quickly be working on the story I
thought I was gonna read it if you're
gonna read it read it right what is this
really about your husband you're not my
mother
Wow that was pretty intense mommy daddy
no Oh jr. scar sorry you heard that all
for your childhood video and we edit
that out